[Music]
greetings [ __ ]
that's the thing about easy [ __ ] is
there's a reason why it's easy usually
like when i think back to high school
there's always that girl like at my high
school is this girl linda and you know
she had a reputation you know she was
easy you could have sex with linda those
chicks never [ __ ] me well all the
chicks with their reputations they would
eat ass and suck dick
never sucked my dick one i finally got
one like after high school right he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] expert
but then you look back and you realize
like
like i see now with hindsight oh yeah
she had a single mom her dad was
probably [ __ ] finger blasting her
before he got kicked to the curb there's
a reason why she was sucking everybody's
dick she had a horrible childhood
or are you talking about these girls
that'll come back and blow you they're
they're drug addicts or they you know
there's always something wrong it's it's
very rarely a you know self-actualized
woman that's going to come over your
motel room and let you stick your tongue
in her ass the first night she hasn't
even wiped she has you haven't even
asked her do you ask i mean do you do
you take put the ass in the sink and
give it a little rinse before you go to
town oh they have to take a shower oh
they do yeah i don't just have a dirty
ass from the bar i don't know what the
[ __ ] you've been sitting on this [ __ ]
yeah toilet taking this [ __ ] not wiping
your ass no no no no no no first thing i
do is we swap a little spin maybe not
even that just go in the shower together
and you wash your ass you watch her and
you say whatever i wash that ass you
know me i'll take that irish spring i'll
shove it right up that [ __ ] monkey
and pop that dog punch on the stomach
back out [ __ ]
bathing i don't give a [ __ ] jack
but i don't really like punching the
stomach yeah you pop the soap in and you
punch the soap pops back out
these are jokes folks nobody punches
nobody in the [ __ ] stomach
we're just having a good time on a
wednesday night it was weird because
when i moved back
i moved back to jersey in 93
i was just starting to get momentum as
an open mic and i stayed with him and
his wife his wife was pregnant
and he would go out seven nights a week
and get [ __ ]
up
he would get [ __ ] up
and he would go i'm paying you to stay
on my way
and his wife and me would get chinese
food and see caucus there was a place
that was open till 2.
every night at 11 we get 50 worth of
chinese food
egg rolls fried crab rantoons whatever
the [ __ ] you call rangoon rain goods we
would we would destroy that [ __ ]
thing
[Laughter]
so when she was pregnant i would smoke
pot and she might please don't smoke pot
with a dog yeah and i would go what the
[ __ ] just smoke a little bit and she
would smoke a little bit when the baby
was born they had to keep her in the
hospital for an extra day
because the baby was [ __ ] up the baby
came on
this [ __ ] and it's next to like those
little donuts but it says like pie
filling i was always too scared to get
it i don't know what the [ __ ] that is i
didn't know if you had to bake it or
something i'm always going to host this
apple pie type really that was part of
my game growing up that's a quick filler
that's just nothing but glazed yeah it's
glazed with a [ __ ] can of coke oh my
god
the dentist is like that's my boy [ __ ]
that's my [ __ ] right there
that's the money in the bank oh my god i
love you you see him unloading the truck
out back your dentist you know now you
eat that hostess and it's [ __ ]
horrendous
that food is all horrendous they've
taken chemicals out they've added
chemicals in remember the hostess
cupcake just the plain chocolate with
the little [ __ ] thing yeah the little
swirl a little swirl they gave you like
a little heavy little dot of [ __ ]
sperm in there yeah now they give you
nothing it's like some [ __ ] little
[ __ ] with the head
shoots a little gun in there with a
little [ __ ] little you got to eat 10
pounds of chocolate to get to a little
[ __ ] hippie sperm it's one drop yeah
load of sperm in there from the guy at
the factory now nothing some skinny guy
coughing who eats egg whites
i used to be like a guy a diabetic blew
a hot thick one inside a cupcake [ __ ]
94 when i got out of the prison the
halfway house and all that stuff and i
started doing bl i was doing always by
myself
a chick would not come in that door
unless i already shook her down
what joe what do you mean by that what i
mean by that is this girl that i'm
bringing into my [ __ ] cubicle of
death
is not coming in on a maybe yeah she's
either going to suck my dick she's going
home right right there was no he's got a
role to play yeah
no we're not
once we get inside there was no plan
once i get in first thing i'm gonna do
is set up a line make you take your
panties off and suck my dick
so i know what time it is there's no
[ __ ] around
you think i'm done you think i'm [ __ ]
crazy you think i'm crazy first thing i
do when a girl comes over in those days
is i'd say she pee oh my god it's great
to be here put the heater on yeah and
i'd go hold on i'm cutting the line
let's see what you got under that
[ __ ] skirt and i either eat that
monkey just to get out of the way why
are we gonna sit here for three hours
with this monkey in the way because the
whole time you're thinking about how
[ __ ] what positions look at her
thighs let's get that [ __ ] out of the
way how often would it work
every [ __ ] time really no no because
before
listen to me before she came through the
door she was already qualified
like she was already asked shaken down
like if you understand
i'm gonna do more blow i'll come back
with you
let me tell you something i don't [ __ ]
around you're a savage right yeah what
do you mean what i mean is we're gonna
do a couple of lines i'm putting you to
work
and they would look at me and go
you're [ __ ] crazy or yeah i know what
do you mean by what i'm giving you drugs
i'm turning you out and then i would say
it right now you're gonna take some dick
i'm gonna eat your [ __ ] and they will
just look at me because we're not going
to [ __ ] around we're not going to make
out i don't make out what am i 10 i
don't make that one no but i want to eat
that ass i want my dick sucked i want
you to play with your [ __ ] i won't do
all creepy [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
play with your [ __ ] let me watch it
while i whack off and put a coke rock in
your ass this is nothing about love
there's nothing to flip over you know
this is [ __ ] nothing this was [ __ ]
great and it worked
all the time and then you cuddle and eat
her [ __ ]
out have you been on a plane recently
where they still have ashtrays oh yeah
you ever get a little yeah they still
have extras and they're like what the
[ __ ] yeah how old is this how old is
this [ __ ] play yeah think of being in
a plane and being able to smoke i still
remember that yes at the back
you got to sit in the back the back
people would be [ __ ] sparking up like
nothing happened yeah i don't remember
that but i remember going to restaurants
as a kid and there was a smoking section
non-smoking section
my dad used to smoke
three packs a day my mom smoked a pack a
day and we would drive we you know it's
in new york where it's cold you got the
windows up six months of the year
and uh
just chain smoking just sit in the back
i had asthma too i would i'd be having
[ __ ] asthma attacks and so he cracked
the window to give me some air just to
crack and then he would fly remember he
would flick the cigarette at the crack
you know like like somehow it was
magically sucking the ash out it was
blowing it in the back seat so not only
inhale and [ __ ] smoke were covered in
ashes
[Laughter]
[Music]
gonorrhea
chlamydia and all that no there wasn't
even chlamydia in 79 79 it was just
syphilis
and something came out of your dick
that's it all of a sudden over the years
they've added all these dimensions and
names to throw you off yeah it all
started with funk the head of your dick
swells up
blood comes out and i'm saying the nuts
are purple you go crazy yeah you got
good ones you go crazy oh my god you sit
there and go what did i [ __ ] what type
of animals did i [ __ ] what planet is she
from yeah and i'll tell you something
knock on wood i could be honest on this
show it never happened to me i just shut
up
i had crabs
i've gotten crabs
and then i was [ __ ] around with these
dirty college girls when you mess around
with college girls bro you're always
gonna get something you're [ __ ] the
whole campus yeah you got foot fungus
something i had this i had this little
leakage coming out of my helmet yeah and
then i noticed that both of them like
when i was sleeping with one for a while
and then she moved and i started
sleeping with the other one
both of them had this like white leakage
from their little monkey it was
chlamydia but i wasn't embarrass him and
tell him i just get wiped and kept
eating that ass you know me
this got nothing to do with uncle joey
it's like finding a hair in your
hamburger you can get rid of it eating
that [ __ ] you know people send the
hamburger back come on before you send
them hamburger back think back at how
many [ __ ] you licked
right wrong you ever get these
[ __ ] i was hearing my food come
in let me talk to you
you take the hair out and you proceed
you're gonna send the sandwich back and
now they're gonna spit in it
you know because that's what you do when
somebody's saying that's like yeah
what's wrong with hair let me put a
[ __ ] coke snack from tuesday in that
[ __ ] wait till you crunch into
that and think it's a grape
i got a hemorrhoid oh you know i'm gonna
rub the hemorrhoid on your french fries
not even you take you squeeze the
hemorrhoids you get that hemorrhoid
juice it's like that black [ __ ] tart
it comes out they think it's romelade
sauce these [ __ ] jerk [ __ ]
gentiles
so i grew up with his grandson i grew up
with that little irish clan you know
yeah and there's a scene where they go
she goes to watch the fight
and she goes to the church to light a
cannon on the candle the church is
[ __ ] packed
you know it's 1940 something that's all
these [ __ ] irish people had you're
right that's all they had this is it
they worked they got you know because
how you see arabs now
and [ __ ] you know uh black people
whatever i don't mean to insult nobody
but you know the flavor of the month is
you know arabians right like they get
tortured whatever
67 years ago
80 years ago
80 [ __ ] years ago was the irish yeah
you know uh 90 years ago was the chinese
what do you mean was the flavor of the
month like the new people in the new
group who do you hate this year oh who
do you hate what do you hate this year
so every year dozens of different
migrations came in right you know we use
the chinese people to build our
railroads we used to [ __ ] whip them
over a canyon with dynamite stuck to
them they were the original [ __ ]
terrorists did you know that is that why
they make all the fireworks you know
what we've done the [ __ ] chinese
people they gave us the orange yeah they
gave us so much and for years we just
called them [ __ ] yeah the funniest
line i ever heard was in the
in uh
you're the dragon when the chinese guy's
talking to the to the try and he goes
behind our backs they call us yellow
[ __ ]
you know for years nobody had respect
for the chinese yeah but you can cubans
use them too cubans brought the chinese
in the biggest chinatown in the country
right 1960. fidel doesn't [ __ ] with
chinatown right you know we just
discussed this on the podcast it's
amazing to see a chinese guy speaking
cuban but then you know this country
hated the irish mcbastard then the
sicilian the italians came in then they
turned the hate on them
and then the [ __ ] south that you know
then the [ __ ] boat from cubica who we
think when i came in the 50s cubans were
cool remember we had my uncle on
remember we had my uncle
thank you
50s
now what would you rather put up i hate
the [ __ ] cubans i hate the arabs
yeah i'll tolerate the cubans they make
a good sandwich i got hooked on twinkies
one night twinkies was the first sugar
buzz i had because my mom
i would go to my mom and go mom i'm
going on a school trip and instead of
just buying me two twinkies she'd buy me
a box and say sharon with your friends
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you you would hoard this next
listen i would start eating those
twinkies at 11 o'clock at night the
night before before the odd couple
i remember the first all-nighter i
pulled on twinkies one all-nighter on
twitter
and instead of snorting like when you do
blow you do like blurry 20 minutes when
you pull along lightly yeah [ __ ]
guys this is the funniest [ __ ] story
of all time
i pulled an all-nighter on twinkies one
day
before we went to philadelphia and with
betsy ross did the [ __ ] letter yeah
was she the letter the way she made the
flag
yeah and we went to see the nutcracker
suite
my mother bought a box of those a box or
something else in a box of something
else
and it was the first addictive
personality that i ever showed i did not
know it then
i thought about it years later
how i kept watching him you know i
started with the our couple
ah the honeymoon let me eat another
twinkie
then uh the octopus the twilight zone i
gotta have a twinkie for the twilight
zone
and this time i'm gonna get two and some
milk to dilute him it's a one hour yeah
it's a one hour we gotta get two
and then at one i watched something else
i had hbo when i was a kid so i watched
something else yeah you know hbo was
brand new oh hbo late at night
frank whenever i know you in the late
movie when i was a young man seven when
that happened not when i was seven
when i that happened i was in the eighth
grade so i'm talking about 78 the hot
movie at the time they kept playing
that you'd whack off two was
kentucky fried movie or the groove tube
the group had a chick that ran across
naked with her titties i don't know i
like that i like weddings that are just
uh
just parties the wedding i went to new
jersey
if there was a hundred people at the
wedding
84 would do a blow at the reception yeah
so the cake nobody was touching cake
nobody even thought of eating the meal
everybody still had [ __ ] roast beef
and
half a chicken on the table
i thought everybody was sweating
everybody had their tie off that dance
floor was [ __ ] jacked i had never
seen nothing like that yeah
there was a line at the bathroom all the
conversations were in the bathroom
that was the wedding of 87 i remember
sitting there going how [ __ ]
embarrassing is this and the family
families like the old people were
sitting like why are they all in the
bathroom yeah everybody i remember going
into the bathroom and there was a
thousand drinks which draws them
like everywhere in the men's bathroom
toilets because guys are just going in
there
and leaving their drinks in there are
they still married
uh no
longer oh my god they got divorced 10
years later they're long gone but that's
the wedding where i found out where the
houston did go
she was there no
the guy that got married on the car wash
yeah
and he told me that whitney houston
would come in
and when they would sweep the back of a
car it would be empty bundles yeah like
she would take bundles and throw them in
the back seat i'm like
not only is this a bad wedding but these
guys are lying to me yeah
yeah feel like that
doesn't do cocaine no look look at the
[ __ ] story
yeah i'll tell you who else had a badass
wedding you know who else had a badass
money
the first time i got married was one of
the [ __ ] craziest things
because i got out of prison
i got out of prison in february and i
knocked her up in april
and i mean i was snorting i was doing
everything with three hands it's like
nothing had happened and i'm in the
halfway house
so my goal was to get out of the halfway
house so we set the wedding for nine
nine of eighty nine
that was the wedding date the
anniversary just fell a couple days ago
we would have been married i don't know
20 something 29 years would have been
married and
she
the whole family on her side
was in that i was clean and sober
that changed my life
and i had a weekend pass from the judge
so they couldn't piss me till wednesday
legally
so i knew i was gonna go [ __ ] a wall
off the reservation
so we get to the church my brother's
flying and he's gonna be the best man
but he had gone to a wedding the night
before
he went to a wedding the night before
and got on a red-eye
and came to colorado and when he walked
in i had a couple of my friends come in
when he walked in the priest pulled me
aside the priest goes i don't know if
you know what i did
before i was here i worked with drug
addicts in san francisco
your best man that's not gonna work
today he's got rings around his nose the
night before
that's how [ __ ] up he was so another
friend of mine georgie had to step in
and be my best man but mike was in the
back [ __ ] habit yeah he was the guy
that would sue everybody i had a friend
that would
went on a sewing spree he teamed up with
this jew lawyer
and they were just suing people
one after the other he got tons of money
he got one because he was carrying the
tub up
a thing and the tub got cut he got one
stitch the guy got him 200 large his jew
was a [ __ ] savage
he got him another one and then he got
his wife one because she was walking
down the street with groceries
and the kid was on a bicycle on this on
the street she was on the sidewalk this
is how good this jew was as an attorney
and the car cut the bike off the bike
went into the sidewalk and hit my
friends
and she fell down nothing happened
he got hurt like 80 000
because she sued the property owner for
not having offense yes jew is just
notorious yeah yeah so my mic at the
wedding being coked and he's like i got
eight thousand in my pocket and i got
about four working you know what i'm
saying that means he had four lawsuits
working
they were suing people he was getting
commissions the guy's name was cozy
c-o-z-z-i
i'll never forget that though you need
money go see cozy
like cozy would sue you you just go see
him and then he'll come up with the case
for you
yeah come up with something did you fall
in love it's a pitch meeting yeah it was
like he was tremendous
but i'll never forget he was loaded mike
was loaded at the time
we got married at the saint sacred heart
church and
now we got to go to this courtyard
marriott for the reception but
nebraska's playing colorado that day one
of those big
games and my buddy's a degenerate
gambler
so as soon as we get to the reception he
goes right up to my wife's family he's
like where's the tv
and they're like tv there's no tvs here
these guys he brought like three of his
friends my other buddy brought like two
of his friends
they probably had an ounce and a half a
blow between them
we were in the bathroom with my wife's
brother
she had two brothers but one of the
brothers joe king was crazy
we were in there was like a blizzard in
there
as soon as you walked into the bathroom
we were snorting with three hands i was
crying at the wedding i had [ __ ]
my nose was leaking and my wife knew i
was doing blow she was
the poor girl was like trying to play it
off yeah but what broke the wedding
wasn't my money's like i'm serious i
need a tv
and then like there's no tv's here he
rented a room
he went up to the room he took the tv
from the room
brought it downstairs we gave the stock
clerk 20 bucks an extension cord so at
the table he had the game on
during the wedding during the wedding he
was young
do you know my wife mentioned in the
divorce she's like at the wedding your
friend had a tv at the [ __ ] table
did the photographer get a picture of
that i have no [ __ ] right i would
love to see that picture i think i
ripped all those pictures up i ripped
them all out soon we got the voice that
rips those pictures candy bars are
called the marathon bar and it was like
it was straight with strings of caramel
covered in chocolate and then twisted
into a braid
and you you you [ __ ] you took a bite
of that and your salivary glands opened
up like the hoover dam it just your
saliva attacked this piece of chocolate
heaven and you chewed the [ __ ] out of it
because it wasn't like the new caramel
where it just it's goo and slides down
your throat this was caramel you had to
earn
you you were at your jaw chewing on this
[ __ ] and the chocolate is mixing in with
it and the saliva is mixed in and you
swallow it and you got to take a break
before the next bite you got to give
your jaws a couple seconds between sets
and they take another bite and you know
that that's a workout that was good 15
20 minutes to eat the marathon bar
do you guys ever have whoopee pies
whoopie pies are the best those are
stuff
so you know that thing those chocolate
caramel that's a good training thing for
young [ __ ]
like when they're 18 you get them into
the festival listen before you can get
anybody got to suck on these for a month
so you really get a good job no but i'm
ready to suck a dick no you're not yeah
yeah
it's a matter of second dick is a
marathon it's a completely different
situation you just you know you just
been blowing you know [ __ ] guys in
high school we're taking that to the
major league we're trying to get we're
trying to get the big 200 out of these
guys
[Music]
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]